hey
it's movie retrospective time once again
this one was kind of a this is an out of
left field kind of choice
i only picked this one i picked this one
for two reasons one
because um i had seen this come up on
like a lot of
underrated horror lists and i had never
seen it and
shutter just happened to add it and i
was like oh i kept hearing about that
movie it's australian
and i was like so maybe we should check
it out and then which i'll review it
next time
patrick see he doesn't even know yeah
you know well we saw a lot of them
i'm trying to remember which one that
was i get all that get them all confused
yeah because i remember
since you start talking about it it's
basic yeah it's basically the
setup of it it's basically like the
australian
carry kind of oh okay telekinesis movie
yeah that early 80s movies right it's
from 1978
78 okay yeah it was a good movie this
was an
as quentin tarantino dubbed it well the
very funny thing about this
okay so i guess when this was originally
um
released in the u.s that it was
dubbed over with american actors just
like mad max was which is stupid
but i'm happy to report that the version
on shutter has uh the australian and
some of the actors are british too like
i think the main actress that plays
uh k or kathy in it is she's british so
everybody has their normal accent i
think
you know they always claim well you know
the american the american market may not
be able to understand what they're
taught i don't think that's what it was
i think it had something to do with with
contracts with some kind of contract
agreement
that if they were going to release a
movie in the united states there had to
be a certain amount of americans working
on it that's
probably what it was and it just gave
money to some voice actor in some studio
that was going to dis
distribute it for all it was yeah maybe
i mean it well it could be it could be
both things
yeah you know what i mean it could have
been like a win-win but yeah that always
because no man max [ __ ] has suffered
tremendously for from from
dubbed into like with american accents
it's like they're gonna fool anybody
yeah
thinking that it's an american i could
tell it was dubbed he even wouldn't be
even backed into
everything like [ __ ] it just looked like
[ __ ]
it didn't make any sense until i saw it
with you with the original soundtrack
and all of a sudden like oh man
this isn't just a flick this is a film
this is a you know this is a movie a
film a film
with a capital s yeah this is a film
yeah it was good man
yeah dubbing dubbing english to english
it [ __ ] is stupid man
that is dumb like the thing is okay if
if somebody has
really thick australian accents or
really thick scottish accents for
example or something like that but it's
still
english i mean then just put the [ __ ]
closed captioning on
if you're that worried about it well
they didn't have that back then in the
back of the day but
you know i i i can understand it
i can i can i can understand pretty much
any english and if i
can't i still know what's going on just
by the tone of what's happening you know
you can understand it context clues yes
didn't they teach you guys
yeah you can understand it but yeah so
this is an australian movie it came out
in 1978
and the setup of it is basically so you
get an
opening scene with the titular patrick
and i guess he's in i really love like
the opening scene of this it's so
[ __ ] weird
where he's like in the house would i
presume his parents i don't know if it's
his mom and a stepdad
or just like or an uncle or her mom's
friend or something i don't know like
that i don't know or it might just be
his dad
so he's in his room and he can hear like
the parents having sex
like next in the room next door and
i guess like this pushed him over the
edge but they did like this really great
scene where like this grass that's
it's pretty graphic but it's like this
gross ass dude like is coming over and
he's like yeah yeah
red and he's like getting on the
middle-aged lady and stuff and they show
it but it's like in the reflection
of like the the metal ball thing like on
the [ __ ] frame of the bed
and then they show like a split screen
like the wall and here's patrick over
here like leaning against the wall of
his bedroom and here's like this ball
with these two old people [ __ ] on it
yeah and it's like he basically just
flips the [ __ ] out
his parents in and they're taking a bath
together for whatever reason they're
like
and they're being like that and patrick
just can't [ __ ]
take it anymore so he throws a heater in
there and electric eats him
damn and then and then at some point
i i forgot like how did he end up in a
coma though like did the house burn down
i don't think that wasn't real clear
it's just to me
a lot of stuff wasn't clear but what i
did like about the movie is that
it it kind of like it's kind of like
what poltergeist
is like yeah that's phenomenal like what
happened at mammoth mountain
yeah and it's this movie is about that
yeah you know it's about
psychokinesis rspk which is recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis and they
pretty much
got it down uh it's just that
like you said the movie said it's kind
of strange it's a movie of its time
yeah that's that's that's that's the
issue that's the problem but it's still
enjoyable i like it too i think it's a
little bit of an underrated
uh gem from australia from this time
period
well but the thing is about it though is
that a lot of horror movies from the 70s
like had this tone it like seemed
strange to us now i guess because
i mean i was a little kid in the 70s and
then like most people seeing this like
weren't even born then so i do feel like
that's always going to be kind of like
because we don't live in that time
period anymore so it's always there
going to be like that one
one or two like uh you know one or two
removed from that
yeah so but it's not as odd as you know
some of the other ones that i've seen
kind of imagine a little bit like the
exorcist a tone kind of like that
a little bit mixed with remember that
italian movie with the [ __ ] young
girl who was
killing people and they had the perviol
fat dude who was trying to screw her
alice sweet alice alice sweethouse kind
of like
the tone was kind of a mixture of alice
sweet alice in the exorcist to me
this does actually kind of the tone of
this yeah does kind of remind me of
alice whedon
now sweetheart yeah it had that weird
kind of odd kind of cheap
feeling but it it was still good yeah it
felt
this is kind of like that yeah so your
main character our main character
is well patrick but he's in a coma for
the whole thing which
i have to say shout out to that [ __ ]
actor other than the opening scene
um where he's you know killing his
parents and stuff
the rest of the movie he's in bed
in a coma with his eyes wide open and
staring
and i'm not real sure how they did this
but he his eyes don't [ __ ] move
or blink or nothing it's like even when
there's one scene later on where they're
like flashing like a strobe light
in his face and his eyes just don't you
could make something
you can make a little wire return i
guess it had to be hold your eyes up and
then they could do like the old
dropping eye droppers like in [ __ ]
clockwork orange yeah because the whole
like that the whole time i was sitting
there watching going how the
[ __ ] did they do that it's like nowadays
they'd probably do it with cg but it's
like they didn't have that in 1978 so
i'm like to that guy that poor guy just
had to like sit there with his eyes open
and like
practice so like the strobe didn't make
him blink or anything like that holy
crap
it was amazing they did something they
had to oh yeah i
for a while i was thinking maybe they
used like a still photograph
of him yeah and then just and then like
fleck the light over or something like
that i don't know it didn't
it didn't really look like that but i
guess you could do it like that but yeah
so
um he's been in a coma for three years
he's supposedly
brain dead but they're keeping him alive
because like the doctor at this
this is a private hospital and it's a
little bit
sketchy i guess you know whatever the
doctor that owns it is a little bit
sketchy
a little bit mad sciencey the nurses are
kind of sketchy too
everybody that works there is kind of
sketchy so it's like there is like a
whole sketchy vibe going on i'm thinking
about [ __ ] screwing this dude who's a
damn
in a coma well you know what there is a
reason for that
and i guess it didn't really occur to me
while i was watching it but i kind of
thought about it later but i'll get into
that in a little bit he's
manipulating her mind maybe um it might
have been that but i think there was
another
uh there was another aspect of that too
okay but um
so so there's a sketchy hospital he's
staying there and it's like they
i guess they could pull the plug on him
because they said that he doesn't have
any like
living relatives nobody comes to visit
him or nothing like that but the doctor
that owns the hospital is like really
fascinated by
uh you know what is the line between
life and death kinda
and so he's kind of using patrick as
essentially a guinea pig
they don't show it until later on in the
movie but he's doing like electric shock
therapy and also he's trying to like
figure out
where the line between life and death is
and consciousness and all this other
stuff so he's using him as like an
experimental
project i guess and that's why they
haven't unplugged him yet even though
he's supposedly
brain dead so you get this
new nurse who's british and she comes to
work at this
place who's she's like a psychiatric
nurse or i don't know what the hell kind
of nurse she is but i guess she'd
she'd been working in britain and this
is the first job she's getting in
australia
so she gets interviewed by this really
creepy like
head nurse matron person um is this a
catholic thing because they or was that
just like the head
gear that they were at that i'm not
really sure i thought i thought it was
catholic it might be
it might have been a catholic funded
hospital because in certain countries
they do that i don't know you know
the catholic church does it but then
there's other ways that
catholics get involved with the
hospitals too and which
or maybe not catholics but catholic like
interpretations there was some weird
[ __ ] you know what i mean they're into
real estate and all kinds of business
ventures so yeah i'm hard to tell i'm
not sure if that was just something that
was just like a generic
like matron nurse head gear or if that
was like a nunny kind of a lot of stuff
at that time you know
i went to a school that was a military
school that was just kind of a generic
christian military school or christians
running that but
it wasn't organized but not like real
hardcore any kind of
particular denomination yeah it was like
generic just like you know you could be
any
it was just jesus see let's just think
about jesus just generally
on yeah on a certain day like a happy
clappy yeah happy clappy
that's for kids yeah what i mean they
didn't even hardly have any bible
stories
just songs well because a lot of those
are fraught with peril
like for little kids feel like we
weren't little kids you know
middle school it was like you know
it was uh you know from my generation
most of those you know
private schools that that involved
christianity it was a generic
christianity
yeah i i maybe being called
christian allowed you to have certain
kind of tax breaks might have been
something like that i
imagine yeah but a lot of the staff were
yeah christian
knee you know i guess christian adjacent
yeah
sure but it's it's about making money
going to work
more than anything else well yeah yeah
most things are there's a school
correctly in the curriculum that they
had to go through and
on one day a week we had to go to chapel
but that was we liked that because that
got us out of class
yeah yeah they get up there and [ __ ]
play guitar and [ __ ] sing and [ __ ]
let me sing along with it it was only
like a half hour
yeah yeah that kind of [ __ ] okay i don't
even remember the songs
yeah i don't really well i didn't get to
release this they had the overhead
projector with the download lyrics and
[ __ ]
so you could do karaoke we had a little
bouncing ball
yeah it was funny because we were mostly
just
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off and joking
around well yeah i think
seriously the world over yeah kind of
does that like look at each other
[ __ ] you know
throwing [ __ ] at each other spit balls
and stuff paper
[ __ ] i'm gonna get you oh no we
gotta sing you know
shut up we're gonna get in trouble yeah
yeah yeah this [ __ ] [ __ ] 12 12 year
olds and 13 year olds do
well yeah yeah so uh so this nurse uh
comes to work there
and because she's the newbie she gets
put in charge
of patrick who apparently i guess he
needs like um
24 7 care because i guess they need to
like
his eyes don't close apparently so they
have to like put drops in his eyes and
they have to like
change his bedpan and all this other
kind of stuff the doctor seemed like
really
concerned about when he was going to
have a bowel movement he would just like
ask the nurse he's like whatever the
nurse is always considered that when he
was [ __ ] rocking up too yeah
and then she said that to another nurse
and the nurse didn't even ask her how
big it was
i was like why are you bringing this
[ __ ] up if you weren't measuring it
because you think the other girl will
like go yeah you know what are we
talking about we're talking about like a
mushroom
we're talking about like a stack of d
cells what are we talking
yeah they never show it but the movie
does kind of go there i mean it does
kind of
imply that like okay so the thing about
it is that so everybody thinks that
patrick is
brain dead like i said the doctor even
says look we put him on like the [ __ ]
ekg machine
for you know however long so several
days or weeks or however long it was
it's like all it registered was like
farts and
nothing it's like there was nothing it
didn't register anything so he's totally
brain dead
however what kathy finds out because she
kind of gets fascinated by
patrick um is that he seems to be
conscious he has a consciousness
rattling around in there
like at first she's leaning over him
like changing a sheet or something like
that and he kind of spits on her
so she's like what the [ __ ] and then the
other nurse was just like oh he does
that every now and then it's just like
you know a reflex action and that's what
the doctor says to that's what everybody
says it's like he's you know he's not
in there he's just spitting it's like
that's just [ __ ] that happens and
there's a really horrible
scene and i really hope to christ they
did not kill an actual frog to do this
scene but it kind of looks like they did
so
trigger warning i'm just telling you but
the so the doctor is like
yeah you know it's a reflex action and
then he takes one of his frogs because
he has a box of them for whatever reason
and like sticks a you know a needle like
in its brain
and like puts it down and thing she's
like which it which was dumb because
she's like dude i'm a nurse i know what
a [ __ ] reflex action is you don't
really have to kill a frog in front of
me to like
demonstrate yeah this is what it is and
see like his leg still moves when i put
an electorate on it i'm like yeah
we did that in biology yeah that's why
they did that and that's they could get
away with that because they do that in
biology
classes yeah we did vivisection on a
damn turtle and yeah we didn't tell them
the turtle's brain dead
we did too yeah but uh you know that's
that's turtles crabs baby pigs
sharks yeah but anyway uh it was a
bummer
i i enjoyed it i didn't really
yeah i mean i didn't mind if the animals
were already dead but the ones that were
like still alive i was kind of only one
that was alive that we dealt with was
that turtle
the shark was neat though i thought the
shark one was kind of funny
that turtle though you know what i mean
it was brain dead his frontal lobes were
destroyed
yeah and we didn't do that the [ __ ]
professor did that yeah you do
they do it with a [ __ ] spike and then
you know
that's what they did to this frog in
this movie like i said i don't know if
they really did it to the frog i mean it
wouldn't
it wouldn't shock me it was nice 78. i
mean
this is australian at italy but because
italy be like yeah kill it yeah torture
them
step on it yeah who cares but uh no they
did that
because they were doing that they were
doing that in school yeah did that in
high school
you know the professors did it but
that's where doctors came from
yeah you know they were just trying to
figure out who could make a good doctor
see who didn't get squicked out by it
well some people were well no some
people just they're like steve you know
he
he got into that [ __ ] he became he was
into biology he became a biochemist
because he was doing really good in
those classes yeah went to ufm and
everything
he ended up on a human genome project
ought to have him on [ __ ] show one of
these days yeah i remember you mentioned
it they had my head i had my friend dr
steve
dr steve oh [ __ ] man [ __ ] he'd tell
all kinds of stories of trouble we got
in
oh yeah sure that would be like a whole
yeah he's like my brother
hell yeah he can't i've met him once he
came here with us for a little bit
yeah but yeah so uh
so she discovers that patrick can
actually
communicate with her he starts by doing
the whole
you know one spit for yes two spits for
now um
so he starts doing that and like
answering her questions but then
it fi it uh comes to pass that he can
actually control
the environment through psychokinesis
you can make [ __ ] come up on the
typewriter
he can do all kind of [ __ ] like that
it's really funny they they kind of um
you know early on in the movie there's
like this crazy old guy that's in the uh
room next door and they and to like show
how
crazy he is he says the doctor says oh
yeah he says patrick flies out the
window at night
yeah but patrick doesn't bodily fly out
the window at night but i guess like his
soul or his sense or whatever he can
like fly around and do [ __ ] at a
distance he's in an out-of-body state
yes
you know his consciousness is outside
his body and you know [ __ ] just like
i said that quantum soul theory and
everything that you know
goes down with me every now and then
like [ __ ] last last night
that's some weird [ __ ] we're going to
talk about on a review we'll talk about
that on a normal show
but uh no uh i'm convinced because i've
seen this kind of stuff before
it just look up uh stewart hameroff's
quantum soul theory he's a doctor
he was into all this um he was into uh
anesthesia he's an anesthesiologist he
just noticed some weird properties that
anesthesia did to people
you know it's a lot of stuff they can't
explain and one of the things is out of
body types
perceptions that they know a person is
not having brain activities but they
remembered things
and you know what i mean and saw certain
things that happened
and he documented it over time wrote a
bunch of books out he has a [ __ ]
explanation for it called quantum soul
theory
which has to do with
that what you call consciousness and
[ __ ] certain parts of your memory
they're quantum entangled particles that
are inside your [ __ ] neurons and
stuff
but they don't need those neurons to
hold themselves together because they're
entangled
so it can kind of float out as a damn
entangled
and entangled [ __ ] mess of [ __ ] uh
subatomic particles and it's still
consciousness it's like your point of
view
and that's what you're that's what's
that's what's having that out of body
experience
but he's not convinced it holds together
forever
you know what i mean yeah but that's
what's being shown in this movie
this is very much a 70s paranormal type
yeah along the lines of carrier the
entity or something like that
psychological yeah whereas like it's not
overtly
gory there are like a couple of you know
horrific type of things that happen in
it but it's not
it's more like a drama mystery
paranormal type of
thing so basically what ends up
happening is that
she becomes convinced that patrick is
actually conscious and he's really in
there
but he does you know like the you know
like the cartoon with the singing frog
where he only sings in front of that one
guy
okay well that's that's what patrick
does he will only do his
[ __ ] like type things on the typewriter
and stuff like that when she's around he
won't do it
he won't spit like on command or
anything like when anyone else is around
and she gets kind of pissed off about it
because she's trying to like prove that
he's actually alive and that he has
these powers
and they do kind of go into the fact
that because he doesn't
that there was one one of the characters
says early on he says you know how
like somebody that's blind or deaf or
something like that how their other
senses become
heightened so they can you know it
adapts they're like well this guy can't
hear anything can't see anything
can't smell anything can't taste
anything so then his sixth sense
is subsequently like that much more
powerful so that's
so they do kind of like explain yeah
that's why
that's how he would exp how was it
that's not how i was seeing it i was
seeing it as
basically he was [ __ ] astrally
projected he was yeah
and like i said i think that's they
implied that as well because with the
old guy next door saying that he saw him
fly out of the window at night because
he could go around and do things
yeah you know in in just layman's term
he was actually projected and he could
[ __ ]
uh had telekinesis and can read people's
minds and
i guess maybe put thoughts in people's
minds i'm not sure
he could actually because there was that
one thing
where because kathy the ma the nurse
that kind of becomes obsessed with him
um she like you know she
she's gotten a thing where she's
separated from her
husband whose name is ed they're still
like friendly but it seems like ed
he like kept keeps trying to like get
her back like there's this really one
really weird scene where she's moved to
her own apartment
and um he like i guess breaks into her
apartment when she's at work and then
she comes home and he like jumps on her
and um i don't know if they actually had
sex or if it was just like implied
because it kind of like was a
kind of a smash cut to the next thing
but then he said something weird like i
was so much for women's rape fantasies
i'm like dude you just broke into by
apartment what the [ __ ]
but it's like so and then like so
there's like a weird relationship
between the two of them and then there's
this other doctor dr brian
who she kind of has the hots for but she
just kind of wants the d she doesn't
really like want to get in a
relationship or anything
so i but i feel like she's kind of
getting pushed toward that guy by this
other nurse who's kind of [ __ ] or
whatever
so i think i saw this mentioned on like
another review
the fact that she gets so
involved with patrick is because all the
men in her life like the doctor dr brian
her ex-husband
they all want to like take care of her
they all want to like kind of smother
her
like you know they're trying to like get
her to go with them
and i think she relates to patrick
because he's helpless
and she can take care of him she can be
in control of him
rather than him being in control of her
you know what i'm saying yeah i think
there's a little bit of that going on
too
yeah because she comes across as like a
very
um you know kind of liberated and she's
like not having it and all this other
kind of stuff but then she's kind of
getting involved with these other dudes
and kind of letting them to me they were
just kind of lame 70s character guys
yeah i mean [ __ ] they were yeah but i
mean you could see
why she developed this kind of
fascination with this guy like i said
now that
you know and once she figured out that
there was actually something going on in
his head and that she started to suspect
that he could
do [ __ ] with his mind and he could do
[ __ ] from a distance too
it's like even though he was his body
was like stuck in this hospital
like because one time he almost drowned
dr brian like in his pool like at his
own house
he made the ex-husband um whose name was
ed i think
uh burn his hands like on the [ __ ]
crockpot or like he put his hands on it
yeah like because i guess like he made
him think like
patrick made him think to do that it's
the same as reported in poultry guys
yeah so he could like control people's
thoughts too like from a distance
yeah so as it goes on like patrick
starts getting more and more
he starts getting like obsessed with her
and she's not allowed to
hang out with her ex-husband she's not
allowed to go out on dates with other
dudes or he will interfere
and like do something she even like
tries he even tries to kill
ed like trapping him in like an elevator
it's like a living ghost story
yeah it's kind of like that basically
just like so there actually
was a sequel to this made the weird
thing about this is that the movie
didn't do all that well in australia but
it did pretty well
in like other countries unlike the us
and europe it was actually a pretty big
hit um even though it's kind of gotten
sort of forgotten now i've never heard
of it quentin tarantino was actually a
big fan of it and evidently i can't
remember what scene it was but there was
a scene in kill bill
that was a direct homage to the scene in
patrick where he suddenly
jumps out of the bed you know what i
mean like pretty much the one jump scare
in the movie
um so there was a sequel to it which i
didn't see
however in 2013 they did a remake of it
called patrick evil awakens
and it's on to be and i watched most of
it earlier today
um just kind of like out of the corner
of my eye while i was working on some
other stuff it's actually pretty good
um the story sticks very close to the
original
but um they ramped up the horror
elements like
big time yeah so it's so it's very very
dark and grimy like a lot of modern
horror movies are
and um you know the the guy next door to
the room the one that said he flies out
of the room at night
it's like he just looked like a normal
old dude like in the original movie but
in the remake he got
really horribly burned so he looks like
[ __ ] freddy krueger and [ __ ] but it's
like
and and you know there's like a lot of
like musical stings like
you know what i mean this all that kind
of thing so that's kind of cheesy but
actually other than that it's it's
pretty good and they actually take like
huge chunks of dialogue from the
original movie like in scenes from the
original movie and
pretty much do them almost exactly the
same plus charles dance is [ __ ] in it
i thought it was okay yeah this is
actually a pretty good movie it's like
if you like
you know movies from the 70s and you
haven't seen this one because i feel
like this one
kind of gets forgotten about a lot of
times because i had only heard of it
because i kept
i kept seeing it on these like you know
underrated horror lists
and i'd never seen it and i was like oh
yeah i should probably get around to
seeing that one of these days
and then it came up on shutter a couple
of days ago so i decided
yeah what the hell and i actually ended
up enjoying it quite a bit like i said
it's not
super horrorific or anything like that
it's just kind of like a paranormal
thriller so yeah it's a long it's along
the lines of like uh
you know the brood or something you know
yeah kind of that kind of vibe or like
you said like alice sweet alice kind of
vibe but you know more of a paranormal
a little bit of the entity in there yeah
like not super
horror like really it doesn't get horror
until that [ __ ]
yeah it's just like kind of weird [ __ ]
but um
and like i said if you want to see the
remake which you know
like i said it sticks pretty close to
the story although you know some people
some characters die in the remake that
didn't die and the
original and stuff like that uh that's
actually on to be for free and it's not
bad at all so if you want to check that
out too but yeah it's on shutter
so if it sounds like something that
would be up your alley
then by all means check it out and we'll
see you next time bye
you